i spent most of my life being terrified
of one thing or another
i can't tell you how to not be afraid
but i can tell you
that i've experienced how to not be
defined by my fears
when i was chosen to perform at the
grammys in 2018
i was so scared for two months leading
up to it that i thought
i might need to be institutionalized i'd
put so much
significance into that one performance
and
i was full of so much insecurity of my
ability to live up to the moment that i
wanted to pull out at times
but when i asked myself why i was so
scared i realized that i was so
terrified because that moment i was
preparing for
symbolized the goals i've been working
for my whole life to achieve
and then i knew that it was something i
needed to push myself to do
i think what makes a successful person
is not being fearless
but pushing through the things that
scare you the most
and this is a song about not being
defined by personal insecurities
or others negative views accompanying me
are mary lattimore and harp karina
depiano
on piano skyler stonestreet and kenna
ramsey
on background vocals and the song is
called shadow
[Music]
do
[Music]
i feel so good
why are you so mad
and i'm so happy
[Music]
in the desert with my best friend seeing
spaceships in the sky
and i love
singing bad words in my songs
as the only people who got time to get
offended are the ones i've probably
never gotten
off so get your [ __ ]
out of my sun
out of my blue skies
[Music]
love you even though you hate me
[Music]
you can
[Music]
in the
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Music]
i'll just keep on doing what i do best
piss enough people who wanna be pissed
hey is the poison loves the elixir
if you don't like me you can suck my
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
you